♪ ♪
>> Geraldo: WELCOME BACK,
EVERYBODY.
CNN BEING CRITICIZED FOR THE
SOFTBALL TREATMENT OF THE
INTERVIEW.
HE COMES IN STARK CONTRAST WITH
THE WAY PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN
TREATED THE LAST FOR TWO YEARS.
REMEMBER?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HOW WAS YOUR FOOT AND WHAT
HAPPENED?
YOUR THIRD RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT, AND YOU MADE IT.
YOU MADE IT.
WHAT DOES IT FEEL LIKE?
SHE AND DOUG EMHOFF, BY THE WAY,
THE SECOND GENTLEMAN, IS HE THE
SECOND DUDE?
WHAT SHOULD WE BE CALLING HIM?
>> THE TERM HAS EVOLVED INTO THE
SECOND GENTLEMAN.
I WILL CALL HIM HONEY.
>> Geraldo: WHAT THEIR
FAVORITE FLAVOR?
DON LANDESMAN PRAISING JOE BIDEN
AND ATTACKING TRUMP.
>> IT FEELS LIKE WE ARE WATCHING
INTERVIEWS FOR PRESIDENT-ELECT
AND A PRESIDENT WHO ARE ON EARTH
ONE AND EARTH TWO.
A VERY NORMAL AND SAFE AND
SEDATE AND IT WAS WELCOMING
NEWS.
WE ARE NO FAKE NEWS, WE HEARD NO
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, WE HEARD NO
PERSONAL GRIEVANCES.
>> THERE CERTAINLY WAS A LOT OF
THE RIGHT ANSWERS.
THERE WASN’T THE ATTACK.
>> IT WAS SO SEDATE I WAS
FALLING ASLEEP.
REMEMBER WHEN THEY WERE ACCUSING
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WITH ABSOLUTELY NO
EVIDENCE OF BEING A SPY FOR THE
RUSSIANS FOR GOODNESS SAKE?
>> Jeanine: YEAH, YOU KNOW,
BEING A SPY FOR THE RUSSIANS, A
PUTIN PUPPET AND ALL THAT AND
NEVER ADMITTING THEY WERE WRONG.
NEVER TAKING THE TASK, THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT STOOD BEFORE
THEM AND SAID I HAVE EVIDENCE
LIKE ADAM SCHIFF OR EVEN PEOPLE
IN THE FBI.
NEVER TOOK ANY OF THEM TO TASK
AND I’VE GOT TO TELL YOU, THE
SADDEST PART OF ALL THIS IS THAT
WE HAVE A SITTING PRESIDENT WHO
IS 74 YEARS OLD WHO HAD COVID
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE OLDER
YOU ARE, THE MORE SERIOUS IT CAN
BE WHEN YOU ARE THAT AGE.
THEY COULD HAVE CARED LESS.
THEY DIDN’T EVEN BELIEVE HE HAD
IT.
THERE WERE ALL KINDS OF THEORIES
IN THIS VICE PRESIDENT-ELECT,
BREAKS HIS FOOT ALLEGEDLY
PLAYING WITH HIS DOG, FRACTURES
THAT, I DON’T KNOW WHAT HE DID
AND THEY ARE ALL CONCERNED ABOUT
IT BUT NOT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEIR HUMANITY IS NOWHERE TO BE
FOUND.
THEY WANTED BIDEN AND THEY GOT
HIM IN.
HE IS THEIR GUY, IT’S THAT
SIMPLE.
>> Geraldo: BUT YOU KNOW WITH
THE PRESS BEING IN URBAN ELITES,
OVEREDUCATED, BASED ON ONE COAST
OF THE OTHER GENERALLY SPEAKING.
MAY BE A COUPLE OF THEM IN
CHICAGO, THEY WILL NEVER GIVE UP
REPUBLICAN A FAIR SHAKE.
PARTICULARLY NOT THIS
REPUBLICAN, DON’T YOU THINK?
>> Jesse: I AGREE THAT I AM
OVEREDUCATED, GERALDO, AND YOU
ARE RIGHT.
I DID SOME DIGGING AND FOUND
TRUMP’S FIRST INTERVIEW AFTER
WINNING IN 2016 BY LESLIE STAHL
AND HERE WERE THE QUESTIONS
LESLIE STAHL ASKED PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
SHE ASKED ABOUT THE STREET
PROTESTS AGAINST HIM, ASKED WHEN
HE IS RELEASING HIS TAX RETURNS
AND THEN DIDN’T EVEN ASK.
STATED THAT BLACKS AND MUSLIMS
ARE AFRAID OF YOU.
THAT’S THE INTERVIEW AND THEN
YOU CUT OR SOMETHING LIKE THIS
AND IT’S LIKE, WHAT DO YOU FEEL
ABOUT HAVING LUNCH WITH, KAMALA
ON A WEEKLY BASIS.
I DIDN’T LEARN ANYTHING COME ALL
THE LAND WAS JOE FRACTURED HIS
FOOT CHASING HIS DOG AND HE’S
NOT GOING TO PUNISH CHINA FOR
COVID-19 AND EVERYTHING HE DOES
IS GOING TO BE REALLY EXPENSIVE.
I WASN’T IMPRESSED BY
JOE BIDEN’S PERFORMANCE AND I I
HAVE TO TELL YOU, I DIDN’T THINK
THOSE CNN GUYS AFTERWARDS WERE
IMPRESSED, EITHER.
YOU CAN TELL, NOT EVEN CNN IS
IMPRESSED WITH JOE BIDEN.
>> Geraldo: MAY BE THE COUNTRY
HAS TO BE IN A COCOON.
MAYBE THAT’S THE BEST PLACE.
MAYBE EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE
SEDATED, TO USE THE WORD THAT
DON LAMENTED.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, IT WAS
INTERESTING, WHEN JAKE ASKED HOW
WAS HIS FOOT AND JOE SAID IT
TASTED FUNNY.
THAT WAS WEIRD.
>> Geraldo: THAT WAS HIS
FAVORITE FLAVOR.
>> Greg: I’M JUST REALLY HAPPY
THAT DON LEMON IS EMOTIONALLY
OKAY BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT THIS
IS ALL ABOUT.
THERE WERE NO BODY BAGS COMING
IN.
HE JUST WANTED TO MAKE HIM FEEL
SO UNCOMFORTABLE, HE IS SO MEAN
AND RUDE AND NOW WE HAVE A
REALLY BORING GUY WHO MIGHT
START WARS.
THE DIFFERENCE IS THE BEHAVIOR.
WITH TRUMP AND AFTER WITH JOE
WILL BE SO STARK.
IT’S LIKE GOING TO BE A DRUG AD
FOR PSYCHOSIS.
BEFORE BIDEN THEY WILL BE
SCRATCHING AT THEIR SKIN AND
EYEBALLING THE CEILING AND
AFTERWARDS THEY WILL BE LICKING
A LOLLIPOP IN SUNSHINE ON A
SWING BUILT FOR TWO AND IT WILL
JUST BE PERFECT.
BEFORE DERANGEMENT, AFTER
DERANGEMENT.
>> Geraldo: DO YOU THINK IT’S
THE HONEYMOON WITH THE PRESS OR
DO YOU THINK IT WILL BE FOREVER?
YOU THINK THEY WILL ALWAYS BE
UNCRITICAL.
SUPREMELY, SUBLIMELY UNCRITICAL.
>> Emily: I’M USUALLY AN
ETERNAL OPTIMIST BUT I HAVE TO
SAY I THINK THIS WILL BE A
FOREVER HONEYMOON AND IT
TERRIFIES ME BECAUSE THERE’S TWO
THINGS THAT IT COVERS UP.
THE GOOD THINGS AND THE BAD
THINGS.
THE FACT THAT THE MEDIA IS
UNWILLING TO ASK CHALLENGING
QUESTIONS, CRITICAL ONES.
THEY DON’T HAVE TO ATTACK THE
NEXT PRESIDENT IN THE WAY THAT
THEY HAVE TWO ILLICIT FACTUAL,
IMPORTANT INFORMATION AND A HALF
THAT ADMINISTRATION BE
TRANSPARENT, WHICH IS WHAT WE
ALL DESERVE, BECAUSE WE PAY THE
SALARIES OF EVERYONE IN OFFICE
BUT THAT IS HOW THINGS LIKE
CONGRESSIONAL SLUSH FUNDS
GET SET UP BECAUSE THERE IS NO
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THAT.
ALSO IT COVERS UP THE GOOD
STUFF.
IF THEY CONTINUE THIS, IF THEY
DON’T ASK THE QUESTIONS THAT GET
REAL ANSWERS, COME THE NEXT
ELECTION, THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO SAY WITH HISTORICAL
ACCURACY ALL THE GOOD THINGS THE
NEXT ADMINISTRATION HAS
ACCOMPLISHED.
THEY’RE SHOOTING THEMSELVES IN
THE FOOT.
>> Geraldo: NO DOUBT THE WAY